bueno es una situación bien difícil la
que se vive en este momento está
penalizado no se puede viajar dentro de
inglaterra dentro del reino unido- y
tampoco a nivel internacional por
supuesto el país está adoptando todas
las medidas necesarias en caso de que
haya un acuerdo break sheet como dices
en 10 días o que no lo haya la situación
más complicada en este momento es con
francia porque ese país además de cerrar
las fronteras para el ingreso de
pasajeros lo ha hecho para los bienes lo
que ha generado que en el canal de la
mancha haya un gran número de camiones
que están intentando ingresar por
supuesto la gente tiene miedo de que se
vayan a quedar sin alimentos frescos en
estos días ya una cadena muy grande de
supermercados ha advertido de que si no
hay una situación que se resuelva
prontamente entonces se podrían empezar
a escasear alimentos frescos como
verduras y cítricos ha dicho en francia
también que espera adoptar un protocolo
con la unión europea rápidamente para
que esta situación pueda resolverse